So, you've probably started building
Claw Code skills, and at first they seem
super simple. You write some
instructions, add context, and suddenly
Claw can produce work that normally
takes a specialist. But then things
start breaking. Skills don't trigger
when they should. Your context window
starts to fill up, and the outputs
aren't getting better. And here's what
most people don't realize. They're still
stuck at level two or three of skill
building. This video is going to show
you what's beyond that. So, I spent
hundreds of hours now in Cyclog Code
studying Anthropic's complete skill
building guide and building over 20
production skills that now run parts of
my marketing strategy and operations
every day in my business. I'm going to
walk you through each level from simple
setups to self-improving systems that
work together as your AI workforce. So,
let's start with level one. Level one is
all about understanding what a skill
actually is. And it's not what people
have been telling you skills are. So, at
its core, a skill is just a folder of
knowledge. That's it. But it's how you
build the files inside of the folder and
the relationship between those files
that actually determines how successful
your skills are. So, let me break it
down with a real example skill that I
found online that I love. So, this is
called the last 30-day skill in this
Ronny Nutrition GitHub repo. And the
idea is it goes out and does trending
research on topics of your choice on
Reddit and X. So, it's able to go and
collect from Reddit and X where our
traditional search cannot do that. It
can bring back information like up
votes, number of likes, retweets, etc.
Now, every skill has one required file,
the skill.md. So, this is the brain of
the skill. It's a markdown file that
tells Claude what to do, when to do it,
and how to do it well. So, you can think
of this as an SOP or standard operating
procedure. So, for example, in our
adapted trending research skill inside
the skill to MD, you can see we've got
step one, pass the request, which
understands the user's intent. Step two,
run the research, which goes out and
collects information from the Reddit and
X APIs. And then you've got three
optional folders. You've got scripts
folder for executable code like if it
needs to grab some data from an API call
like in the trending research skill.
Step two actually goes and grabs the
scripts folder down here and runs the
last 30 days.py which uses external APIs
to go and grab information from those
Reddit and X threads. You've got a
references folder for documentation that
Claw can pull in when it needs it only
like examples of what good looks like.
So in the trending research skill we've
got the references folder and we've got
this brief template. And the brief
template just says this is how you
should return outputs of the research
reports. So notice these aren't in the
skill.md file. And then you've got an
assets folder for things like templates,
fonts or icons, but ultimately they're
all just additional files of deep
knowledge or knowledge that your process
document, the skill.md can and should
reference in its instructions, but
they're only pulled in as and when
needed. And that's the really important
part that anthropic explains in their
full skill building guide. Skills use
what they call progressive disclosure.
And this is a concept you need to
understand because it comes up again and
again. So there are three tiers of
information loading when it comes to
skills. So tier one is the YAML front
matter at the top of your skill.md file.
So this is always loaded into your claw
context. Every time you have a skill in
your folder, this is loaded in. So you
can think of this as just the name and
description of the skill and it's how
Claude decides whether to use this skill
for a given task or not load the full
skill skill.md file in. So for the
trending research, we've got what it
does. Research what's trending in the
last 30 days. the words it's triggered
by, research what's trending, and the
words it is not triggered by. But what
many people don't know is the limit
Claude accepts into its context for
skill descriptions is only 15,000
characters, which is around five pages
of text. So don't install too many
skills or you'll run out of space and
actually bloat your context right off
the start. Now, tier two is the body of
your skill. MD, exactly what we just
saw, the process step, step one, step
two, etc. This only gets loaded when the
skill is actually activated by Claude.
And tier three is everything else. The
reference files, the scripts, the
assets. Claude only pulls these in when
it actually needs them for a specific
step which is deemed necessary by the
instructions in the skilled MD file. So
for example, in the run the research
where it says the script/last 30day
script should be run. It then runs that
script and pulls that from the reference
file only when it's necessary. And that
three tier system is really really
important because it means Claude isn't
loading everything all at once. It's
being smart about what information it
brings in and when. So to use a skill,
all you need to do is drop that folder
directly into your doc. Claude folder
and a skills folder underneath. Each
skill has their own folder. As long as
it has a skill.md, it's considered a
skill and Claude can see and use it. So
at level one, you can take a skill that
somebody else has built. You can install
it and Claude follows those instructions
to produce better work than it would on
its own. Okay, so you can install and
use a skill and that's great. But here's
where most people hit a wall. they start
building their own skills and they think
that more information equals a better
output and that's exactly what level two
is about solving. So I found a really
popular Reddit post called I was wrong
about agent skills and how I refactor
them and the story is so common that I
had to share it. So, this developer
started building skills the day they
dropped. And within 2 weeks, they had a
CloudFare skill at 1,131 lines, a Shaden
UI skill at 850 lines, and an Nex.js
skill at 900 lines. And then every time
Claw Code activated multiple related
skills, the context window exploded as
it was loading 5,000 to 7,000 lines in
every single time into the context
window. And that's because he put
everything in one giant skill.md file so
that Claw could access all that
information up front. But that is
completely wrong. The problem isn't lack
of information, it's actually having too
much irrelevant information. So skills
share the context window with your
conversation. So uncontrolled loading of
unnecessary information is basically a
direct performance tax on your
conversation. So if you built skills in
this way, you'd probably see slowness,
drifting from instructions, and Claude
ignoring the obvious parts of your
instructions. So here's the fix, and
this is the golden rule of skill
building. Keep your skill.md under 200
lines max. And that 200 line limit is
not arbitrary. It's effectively based on
how much context an LLM can efficiently
scan through to decide what to load
next. So we're trying to keep the entry
point for Claude under 200 lines so that
Claude can understand what the skill
offers, decide which reference file it
needs to read and load just that file,
i.e. another file with 200 to 300 lines
only. And that massively reduces the
amount of information you're handing to
Claude immediately and therefore will
improve performance. So you can
effectively think of the skilled.md as a
table of contents that tells Claude
where to look if it needs more
information. So the actual detailed
documentation goes into your references
folder and Claude should only be pulling
it when it needs it and bit by bit. So
it won't overload your context window.
Now the second massive mistake people
make is in the description field. So
this is in your YAML front matter that
we mentioned before. And if you remember
this is how Claude decides whether to
load your skill in the first place. So
if it's too vague the skill will never
trigger and if it's too broad it
triggers on everything. So studies
apparently suggest that skill activation
sits around 20% for skills that you
download from a marketplace. So they'd
activate only one in five times which
kind of begs the question like what's
the point in even installing them if
they're not going to activate. So here's
a simple three-step framework on how to
write it well. Firstly we're going to
write the trigger. So what is the event
or situation in which this skill gets
used? So we can say something like
triggers on these keywords research
what's trending research topic. What are
the things that should not trigger it?
So it does not trigger for general web
browsing or simple URL fing and what is
the outcome that's going to be produced
and effectively what the skill does. So
it produces a research brief that other
skills can consume and it research
what's trending in the last 30 days. And
I'd highly recommend going and checking
any marketplace skill that you've got
installed already. If it doesn't have
these three things, it can be improved
massively. So at level two then you know
how to build skills that are lean,
properly structured, and actually
trigger when they should. And that is a
huge competitive advantage over most
people building skills right now. Now,
you know how to build skills that work,
but you don't have to build everything
from scratch. There's a whole world of
skills out there that you can grab,
install, and make your own. But there is
a catch, and this is something that
caught me off guard when I first started
looking at marketplace skills because a
lot of them are badly built. So, I'm
talking 1,000 lines, skill.md files with
no progressive disclosure, everything
dumped into one massive markdown
document, no references folder, no
scripts like we saw before, just a wall
of text that's going to load into your
context window as soon as the skill is
activated. And the most frustrating part
of that is the actual content is often
really good. The business logic is
solid. The step-by-step processes are
valuable. It's just the structure that's
the problem. So, here's what you can do.
You can grab the skill. You can look at
what's inside it. And you can apply
everything you learned in level two by
refactoring it using anthropics skill
creator skill. So the skill creator
skill effectively as it sounds creates
new skills, modifies and improves
existing skills and measures skill
performance. So this even applies to
skill descriptions and improving
activation of skills. So we're
effectively taking that 1,000 line
skill.md and asking ourselves what does
Claude actually need to see immediately
to know when and how to use this skill
that goes in the skill.md. Everything
else gets moved into the references
folders. I want to show you an example
for this because I want to create a
skill that can help my website be cited
by AI answers like Chachi, Gemini,
Claude. And I found this really popular
one by a guy called Cory Haynes who's
got a sequence of marketing skills that
all have brilliant content. It's got
about 13,000 stars. It does have some
references and even an evals folder. But
when I look through the skill.md file, I
can see it's around 400 lines at the
moment. So although it's packed with
really useful information, we're
probably loading too much into the
context of Claude right away and can
abstract some of this out. So what we're
going to do is just grab the
installation line from here. We're going
to go to our terminal and we're going to
install it like this and we're going to
install it locally into our local
folder. So we'll go through the steps of
installing the skill. We can select AIO
and install it locally. Now what we're
going to do here is just ask our meta
skill creator skill which is an adapted
version of anthropic skill creator
skill. It's going to build all the
context for us and also understand that
actually we want it to be less than 200
lines. So we're going to refactor and
add some more references folder that can
be pointed to and not loaded immediately
into our context window to improve the
performance. It's also going to take a
look at the description and improve
that. So we said take the new AI SEO
skill and use the skill creator skill to
refactor it. I want the skill.m to be
max 200 lines and we want to put all of
the reference info inside the references
folder. There's already a few references
but right now the file is around 400
lines. So, it's gone through and it's
basically worked out what information we
can abstract to different references
files and it's told us exactly what's
changed. So, the skill.md was 400 lines
and now it's 148 lines. So, that's a 60%
reduction in the number of lines that
we're loading in every time we activate
this skill. And it's created four new
reference files. So, authority signals,
AI visibility audits, content type
optimization, and you can see those
inside the references file. So, we've
got more things that we're pointing to
but less information loaded in at any
one point. If we go into the skill.md,
we can see for example in step two where
we've got the AI visibility audit, we've
now abstracted a lot of that information
and put it inside this references file
which Claude code can refer to when it's
at step two only. So the important bit
about the references file and pointing
to other files is that claude code can
load and unload information out of its
context. So during step two, it doesn't
have a huge amount of information from
the other references files. it's just
focusing on step two and it can load in
the AI visibility audit at that point
which is an extra 50 or so lines. As
soon as it's finished with step two, it
can offload it and therefore save our
token usage but also improve the
accuracy of the results we're getting.
So when you think about it like this,
you've now got this incredible ability
to take someone else's domain expertise,
clean it up, structure it properly, and
have it working in your system in an
afternoon. So at level three, you're not
limited to what you can build yourself.
You can pull in expertise from anywhere
and refactor it into a proper skill
format. So that Claude is basically a
specialist running workflows that didn't
even exist in your business in the
morning. So you can build skills, you
can import and fix skills, but up until
now everything has been pretty generic.
And this is where it gets really really
interesting because a skill without your
business context is basically not worth
having at all. And this brings us to the
next level which stops skills giving
generic outputs and starts making them
actually sound like you. And this is a
massive jump in value. If you had a
generic rank my site in AI search tools,
kind of like this one, AI SEO, I imagine
that skill would actually produce decent
content. But an AI SEO skill that knows
your brand voice, your product offering,
your audience, your content pillars,
your competitors, and your positioning
that will produce content that will both
rank and bring you traffic for relevant
queries. So, it's the difference between
ranking for a high volume keyword that
gets you traffic that you can't do
anything with versus ranking for a query
where the person typing has that
commercial intent or intent to buy
already. So, the way you do this is by
adding your business context to all your
skills, giving them all access. So, your
brand guidelines go into that references
folder. Your audience personas, your
tone of voice examples, all should go
into the references file. So, as good as
anthropic skill creator skill is, it can
give you the structure, but you must
also supply the context. So for my own
business, I've built what I call the
Agentic operating system or Aentic OS.
And it's a set of production skills
across marketing, strategy, operations,
and visuals. And every single one of
those skills has my business context
baked in. So we have a separate shared
brand context folder, which has all of
my assets, my ICP, my positioning, my
voice profile. So my marketing skills
know my audience. They know I'm talking
to business owners who want to automate
their ops and aspiring entrepreneurs.
They know my tone of voice. They know my
content pillars. They know the specific
examples and case studies that I
reference again and again. And this is
what makes them so powerful because
Claude isn't just following a generic
process. It's following my process with
my context. So the skill.md for the AI
SEO, we should actually reference to all
of our contextualized information. And
we do that through a context needs chart
where we say inside the positioning in
the brand context shared folder. You
should load in the summary of that
because it helps you understand what
differentiates the brand for citation
worthy framing. So, it feeds directly
into why this skill becomes more
powerful. Then, we also feed in the
ideal customer profile because we need
to know who we're trying to reach in the
AI answers so that everything we're
writing about is directly relevant to
our existing audience. It's basically
only pulling in the right context when
it's necessary to not bloat context.
Exactly what we spoke about so far. And
by the way, you can download this exact
Aentic OS as part of our Aentic Academy
in the description if you want it. We
also have a full skill building course
that we just launched. So, here's how
you actually do it for yourself step by
step. Well, first you identify the skill
that you actually want to build or
improve on. Maybe it's like this AI SEO
optimization one. Secondly, you use the
skill creator skill to generate the base
structure. Get the skill.md formatted
properly with a good description. And
then third, you add your business
context into the references folder. So,
you don't need a separate brand context
folder like this. You just add it into
the AI SEO references folder and make
sure that you have all of that
information and reference it inside the
skill.md. Fourth, you're able to then
test it. You're running it against real
tasks and seeing if the output matches
what you'd produce if you'd done the
task yourself because it should be
totally contextualized to your brand and
business. So, at level four, your skills
are not generic anymore. They're
customized to your business, your voice,
your audience. And that means Claude is
producing work that actually sounds like
you, not just AI generated slot. Okay.
So, now you've got personalized skills
that produce really good outputs. But
here's the question that nobody's asked
yet. How do you know they're actually
producing good outputs? How do you know
that version two that you've made is
better than version one? So, this is
where we move from building to
measuring. So, Anthropic just released
evaluation and benchmarking built right
into that skill creator skill. And this
is awesome because up until now it was
completely vibes based whether it was
giving us high quality output or not.
You had no way to actually measure
whether your changes made things better
or worse. So, say we removed a reference
file. We wouldn't know if that was
actually affecting the quality apart
from reviewing every single output and
making a judgment call on that. And most
good skills go through many iterations
before they really start to solve your
problems in an automated fashion. And
that's exactly what the eval function is
designed for to speed up that learning
cycle. So let's continue with the AI SEO
skill to demo this. So instead of saying
run some tests on my SEO skill, we're
going to say run a new test using the
skill creator evals optimize for making
sure my content follows the content type
optimization pattern. So, I specifically
looked through the reference files and
figured out actually I want to optimize
the results of this test for this
specific reference file. So, is it even
loading in the reference file in the
first place when it reads through the
instructions? And if it is, we're going
to give it a blog content page. Is it
optimizing for a few of these things?
So, the criteria are, does it have one
clear target query per post? Does it
have author bio with relevant
credentials? Does it have internal links
that relate to product or feature pages?
Those are some of the things that are
going to help us rank in AI search
because it shows that we have authority
and it shows that we are a content
pillar for this specific content. So we
said let's test it on this task and this
is the task that we would conventionally
give to the AI SEO skill in the first
place. So assess the chances of ranking
highly using AI SEO rankings for this
page and I've given it a blog page from
automate.io which was my AI agency and
to be honest this was written before I
did any work on optimizing content. You
can see the article is not very long at
all. So, I don't expect this to come
back with stunning results, but what I
want to see is a step-by-step comparison
against the criteria and how we could
actually improve this. But it's going to
run this through five times and test it
against that criteria. So, we can really
see the results of this skill and how it
performs using those reference files.
The evals feature, by the way, also has
a great other feature, which is AB
testing. So if I wanted to actually AB
test instead of test against specific
criteria, I could AB test, for example,
by taking out the content type
optimization reference file and saying
run this same task five times, once with
the content type optimization and once
without it, which ranks better? And it
will come back with a thorough review on
before and after and help me effectively
optimize this skill by saying, does this
even feed into it in the first place or
does this help enhance the quality of
the results? So, I could do that for
every single reference file and
therefore have a really good evaluation
of whether my reference files are
actually benefiting my skill or just
costing me token usage. And you'll have
noticed that we were only trying to
optimize there for three criteria. So,
I'd highly recommend when you run these
emails doing three to five criteria at a
time. So, you're not giving it too much
to think about and therefore it comes
back with a more thorough review of the
different assertions. So, it's creating
an assertions file. Does the output
assess whether there's one clear target
query per post? Does the output assess
whether there's an author bio? Does the
output assess whether there are internal
links related to a product? So, it
spawns all 10 runs, five with the skill,
five without the skill. This is what it
would do in AB testing. But in this
case, we're just doing five with the
skill because we're doing a direct
comparison of the skill to itself. And
it's going to run those in parallel and
then grade those against the three
criteria. And what we get is a really
nice overview of the different
assertions here. What a pass looks like.
And then basically it's saying I'll
grade and aggregate the results once the
run's complete. So, it's going to run
all 10 agents in parallel, score each
against your criteria, and give you a
structured report at the end of it. You
can read the full output from each
variation, see exactly where it passed
and failed, and give feedback directly
into the report, which then feeds back
into improving the skill, and it will
retest that to make sure the
improvements that we've made have
actually fixed the results. And you can
see some of those agents are coming back
now. And then the results get hosted on
your local environment. So you can see
this they we get this really nice report
that is basically the prompt that we put
in. So assess the chances of ranking
highly using AI SEO rankings. It comes
back with the actual output of the
skill. So the skill is basically saying
in this audit.md that it's pretty poor.
The website page does not rank very
well. So it's got three out of 10 for
content extractability. It does not have
a robots.ext. It's weak on the authority
or the citation worthiness. But don't
forget, we're not actually ranking how
the page performed at this point. We're
actually ranking how the assessment of
certain criteria that we put inside the
skill.md is being adhered to. So what
we're actually assessing is does the
output explicitly assess whether the
page has one clear target query in which
it did pass here. Does it assess whether
the page has an author bio with relevant
credentials visible? It did assess that.
And in the first one, the output did not
explicitly assess whether the page has
internal links to related product or
feature pages. And then in the
benchmark, we have an overview of all of
the different runs. So with the skill,
which is the only one important here
because we were testing just with the
skill, it had a pass rate of those three
criteria, 93%. So that's pretty good. It
took 184 seconds to run with the skill,
with the reference files, and took this
many tokens. You can see that without
some of the reference files, it again
had 93% success rate, but actually the
time taken and the tokens was
significantly lower. So actually what
this starts to tell me is can we take
away some of the reference files without
actually compromising the quality of the
output. And that is where we'd run the
AB test to see exactly which files are
improving quality and which files don't
even matter for the quality of the
outputs. We can then also go back to the
individual output feedback and submit
specific reviews to say actually we want
to make sure that in this case the page
it should always check for internal
links. So can we add anything to the
skill.md to make sure that that always
happens. What that will then do is
retest that with the new skill.md and
come back with a whole new set of
results based on the before and after.
Or you can come back here and directly
let it know your thoughts here. So at
level five then you stop guessing
whether your skills actually work. You
can test them, score them, measure them,
and improve them. And that's how you go
from a skill that kind of ranks to one
that consistently can find your content
and produce content that your ideal
customer will actually find through AI
SEO, for example. So now you can measure
and improve your skills, but you're
still the one doing all the manual tests
for improvements. So what if skills
could actually improve themselves, which
takes us on to level six. So things get
really, really cool now. And this is
something that I've been using for my
own Aentic OS that makes a massive
difference. And the concept is super
simple. Your skills should learn from
every interaction and get better over
time. But to do this, you need one
critical piece that most people are
missing. A feedback loop. So let's stick
with our AI SEO skill. Every time you
run it and notice something, that
observation gets captured in a learnings
andor rules file inside the skill.md. So
you'll see that my meta skill creator
has added a rules section when I've
asked it to create that that say
whatever feedback we add will be added
to these rules and the rules will always
be read when the skill.md is read. So
maybe you're running the skill and the
article it produces ranks on page one
within a week. You can go back and note
exactly what worked. So articles that
open with a direct answer to the search
query in the first paragraph seem to get
picked up in AI search more quickly. Or
we had a comparison table in the middle
of this article which increased time on
page. So all of that can actually go
into the rules file and or you can have
a separate learnings file that sits
within your context that on a skill
bykll basis documents what works and
what doesn't work and that then feeds
from your claw.md into every skill that
you use. So for the trending research
skill we'd have specific feedback on
what worked and what didn't work. And
the way this gets updated is we have a
wrap-up skill. So, at the end of every
session, we close the session and any
skill we've used and any feedback we've
been given will be generated and input
directly into this learnings.mmd file on
a skillbyskll basis. And it's just a
line that says something like after
completing a task, review the output
against these criteria, and if you
identify specific patterns or
improvements, then we're going to add
them back to the learnings file. So now,
every time you run a skill, it's
actually checking back its own work. Did
the article actually answer the search
query in the first 100 words? Did it
include structured data patterns from
the reference file? And if it doesn't do
any of that, it logs it automatically.
And this connects us straight back to
level five because you can use your
evals to validate the learnings that are
actually improving our output quality.
So you can run the same eval before and
after the learnings are applied. And
you'll see the difference in your
benchmark scores. They'll start
improving without you actively having to
run these evals. But the key thing here
is keeping the learnings file under
control. So you can't just dump random
notes in there forever or it becomes its
own context window problem. It's feeding
in too much every single time. So the
idea is to keep it structured and prune
the obvious stuff every so often. So
every week we go through the learnings
file and strip out any surplus
information that won't contribute to
quality. So at level six, your skills
are not static anymore. They're actually
learning from every piece of content
they produce, accumulating knowledge
over time, and getting better the more
you use them. So your skill in 3 months
from now will be dramatically better
than the one you built on day one. And
you didn't even have to manually run
evaluations for it. So now that your
individual skills are learning and
improving on their own, there's only one
thing left to solve. They're still
operating independently. So what happens
if they start working together? Now
before we hit the final level, my
YouTube analytics tells me that 94% of
you are not subscribed but still
watching the content. So if that's you,
then head down below, subscribe to the
channel so you can get more value from
the videos that I create. So this is
level seven, the final level where
everything connects. So we're going to
use a copywriting skill now as an
example inside the Aentic OS. Let's say
I want to write a piece of copy for a
landing page. Not only do we have the
context needs that we spoke about
earlier, so it's pulling in all of my
voice profile, the angles that to target
from the positioning, my full ICP, so it
can tailor the copy towards that. Not
only is it doing that, it is connecting
with my other skills to make more
powerful workflows. So here in step
eight, the humanizer gate, before saving
all copy, we pass everything through the
tool humanizer, which basically is its
own set of production instructions to
help apply pattern detection to every
bit of written content to make it more
human written and less AI slop-like. or
inside the content repurposing skill. If
we can't get our transcripts from
YouTube, then we can leverage another
skill tool-you only when it's necessary
to actually collaborate and work
together as one unit to complete a
entire workflow rather than specific
isolated jobs. So, it pulls in info from
my positioning doc. It knows how to
differentiate us from competitors. And
when it writes actual content, the
humanizer runs it through my voice
profile to make sure it sounds like me
and not like AI slot. Now, I want to be
straight with you. This all takes time
to build. So you're not setting this up
in one afternoon, the foundation skills
alone, your voice profile, the
positioning, the ICP, those need to be
built properly first. But once they're
in place, every new skill you add
immediately benefits from that shared
context. Because think about what you've
actually got here. You've got specialist
knowledge encoded into skills
personalized to your business through
shared brand context. Self- testing with
evaluations, self-improving through a
learning process, and coordinating
skills between each other with full
workflows to make sure that nothing
loads more than it needs to at any one
point. And that's not an AI tool. That
is an AI workforce. And the best part is
you don't need to be technical to build
this. Everything I've shown you today,
every single level, can be done by a
business owner who knows their own
processes. The skills handle the
complexity. you bring the context and
the feedback. So, at level seven, your
skills aren't separate tools anymore.
They're a complete system. So, there you
have it. Every level of Claw Code skill
building. And if you want to see how
I've built my own Aentic OS using these
exact principles with 20 plus production
skills running across my entire
business, then check out the Aentic
Academy in the description where you can
download it and set it up today. And if
you want to see more Claw Code content
like this, hit subscribe and give this
video a like. See you in the next one.